Jimmy thank from gamespot here at e3
2016 I'm here at alien worst booth
speaking with Eddie and Eddie can you
tell us what we're looking at here
absolutely so this is the new Alienware
Aurora
it's our brand-new mid tower it's an
incredible gaming desktop we designed it
to support dual graphics liquid-cooled
overclocking and even overclockable
memory so from a performance standpoint
we didn't cut any corners it's designed
for VR so to support the VR requirements
of today and it'll go even beyond those
and support requirements of tomorrow as
well the chassis itself is brand new so
you may not have never seen it before it
is our mid tower it is our smallest dual
graphics desktop ever just really neat
and if I show you inside you'll notice
there's very little room left unused the
system can support up to five storage
drives the USB port middle support up to
dual for e hundred watt graphics cards
that includes dual 1080 s if you're
wondering and then also the the i7k
processor we're gonna be offering it
overclocked up to 4.2 gigahertz across
all four cores so not just a single core
and then liquid cooling is an option as
well it is one of our quietest desktops
ever it comes with what we're calling
always ready mode so the system will
will actually slow down power off the
components and actually always be ready
for you to - won't even you need it
it'll come back to life in a much faster
much more responsive way than a sleep
experience for example but talk a little
bit more about to perform to the system
we designed it so that people could
actually experience 4k gaming give them
room to experience the VR and even 12 K
gaming experiences the fact that it's
launched at $7.99 with a core i3
processor 8 gigs of ram a one terabyte
hard drive and an nvidia geforce gtx 950
gives gamers that are on a budget a way
in and if you have more expendable
income if you want to have a 4k gaming
experience if you want to have an
incredible you know super-powerful
machine you can do that as well
the systems designed to enable gamers
warrant that savvy who aren't that
comfortable performing their own
upgrades of a very very easy experience
when getting in the machine - so for
example when you get into the system
it's very it's very tooless so what I
mean by that is that I if I try to open
the system I just pulled this door it's
like opening our car door it's very
simple and immediately the parts that
become available are the storage drives
so you'll notice towards the bottom you
have two two and a half inch drives I
think it pull pull in and out there's a
three and a half inch drive at the top
and that can actually be outfitted to
support dual two and a half inch drives
so that's for solid-state drives so far
and on the motherboard there's an end to
slot - so you have a PCIe solid-state
drive there that's five solid state
drives maximum and that does not take
away from the potential optical drive
that you have in there - that does not
take away from the expansion cards you
get support and that includes dual by
sixteen graphics cards so lots of
expandability so even if you're at that
studying the night in price point if
you're if you aspire to upgrade we've
already covered the storage drives
they're very easy to get into getting
access to the graphics cards and the
memory is also very simple - I'll show
you there these latches then once I open
them the power supply is on a swing arm
that comes out and they'll show the guys
at home to the camera all the parts are
very easily accessible look at how deep
we've gone into the system without using
a single screw driver in fact this is
our first desktop to allow truelist
graphics card upgrades there are no
screws on these graphics cards no to
lists no thumb screws it's because the
assembly the power supply comes in
allows for the allows of the system a
way to secure those cards safely so
again for someone who's not that savvy
but wants to get curious and tweaking
the machine and doing their own upgrades
the machine is very good for customers
who want to do that it's also a very
clean setup you'll notice the wires are
stowed is best possible and we did not
waste any of the room in here and this
this unit you know as you mentioned has
custom or liquid cooling what what specs
are in this particular machine this is
right here if memory serves correct has
a core i7 processor an nvidia geforce
gtx 1080 graphics card i'm not quite
certain how much memory we've got
installed it's like 4 to 6 here yeah so
that could be that could be an 8 gig set
up then it could be also a 1 terabyte
hard drive setup so this particular unit
was meant to just show folks the all the
design decisions that we made them a
chassis itself which I could continue
talking about - you'll notice at the top
of the system we had this grip this grip
is exactly worked it's exactly the same
as it does on the area 51 it allows
gamers to carry the system comfortably
so it's very natural to carry as they
move it around as I mentioned it is the
smallest dual graphics desktop we've
ever had standard ATX motherboard it is
a micro ATX motherboard as a matter of
fact my great TX motherboard yep and you
know who's this for exactly there are
you know some hardcore PC enthusiasts
out there they're like oh it's all about
building a PC like why would you wanna
you know get a pre-made what do you have
to say it's like those guys so we've
been around for 20 years now and back in
the late 90s it was really tough to put
a system together you had to be very
savvy you had to know how to mix
Hardware you had to know what drivers
were right you had to know which
operating systems supported what game
you really needed help so Alienware has
always been about giving gamers a
solution that they could just turn the
system on and get straight to pc gaming
we haven't changed that mission in over
20 years and now with the aurora we
continue to do that
the system is something that is it's a
no hassles type of experience that is
also very incredible in high performance
so if you want to have the latest and
greatest game the latest and greatest
performance if you want to brag you can
do that gamers who don't want to have to
deal with the the issues and the
complexities of having to deal with
different vendors different
manufacturers returns you know you get
the the service and support that Dahl
offers 24/7 support which is all very
comforting and gives people with peace
of mind and then oh sorry another
technical question how big is the power
supply
yeah so we started a 460 watt power
supply there's also an 850 watt option
as well I don't fit into that into that
same size same size yep the same one
cool final question
price and release date for this guy so
it's available today and as I starting
out price point of $7.99 awesome Thank
You Eddie for more a 3 coverage stay
tuned to game spot calm